Donald Trump this week as a sort of counter
programing effort to the Democratic National
Convention, is traveling each day to different
parts of the country.
Yesterday he was in Wisconsin, today.
I believe he's in, I think Iowa and maybe
Arizona and yesterday specifically in Oshkosh,
Wisconsin.
He showed up, did a sort of rally like event.
I covered it live.
And Trump simply collapsed once again into
authoritarian daydreams or authoritarian nightmares,
really saying he would seek a third term as
president because his first term maybe shouldn't
count, I guess because he was spied on, as
he claims, even though, of course, that is
not the case.
Take a look at this insanity.
And remember, it might be a joke to you and
me.
We might see this as obviously the rantings
of a lunatic, but a lot of his followers agree
with this idea.
They're going to win four more years.
And then after that, we'll go for another
four years, because you know what, they spied
on my campaign.
We should get a redo for you.
Now, obviously, it's an insane idea.
But Trump got this insane idea from some right
wing commentators who started floating.
Hey, you know, listen, Trump didn't really
get a first term because they spied on him
and they impeached him and they did their
Russia investigation.
Trump heard the idea.
So he floats it and now his followers cheer.
And some of them support the idea of a Trump
third term.
Now, of course, Trump will get no third term,
nor will he run for one.
But this is how wildly authoritarian stuff
spreads.
And it is spreading.
Some pundit puts it in Trump's brain.
Trump at some point manic from the crowd.
Cheering floats it.
And then you've got his heart.
Start hearing from his followers who say this
guy deserves a third term because he didn't
really get a first one.
Now, everything about this appearance was
disturbing.
Trump was very manic throughout.
It actually got so bad that Trump started
talking about trying to win the state of New
York in November.
It was so crazy that even Fox News had to
cut away again.
Check it out.
For Republicans, you have to run the whole
board because they sawed off that.
We're going to play for New York with all
of the crime in New York.
I'm going to play for New York, because that
was President Trump speaking Leive, Wisconsin,
at an airplane hangar, calling it a peaceful
protest, not a traditional campaign rally,
really zeroing in on Joe Biden, saying he's
Boston right now.
Biden is up 24 in New York right now.
Trump only has 32 percent support in New York.
There is, of course, no chance that Donald
Trump wins New York.
Trump can certainly win and he can win reelection.
But Donald Trump is not winning New York.
And then Trump absurdly claims that the United
States has corona virus numbers that are better
than almost all countries.
It's difficult to imagine a less accurate
statement.
And then Trump says, the reason you haven't
heard that is because the media, he points
to the back of the room always the media won't
tell you that they released it.
They didn't release it in China, but it came
to the United States and Europe, 188 all over
the world.
Hundred and eighty eight countries all over
We're not going to forget it.
But we're doing great.
Coming back.
We're coming back.
And our numbers are better than almost all
countries.
I will tell you that despite what you hear.
Look at all of them up there, Scott.
Look at all of that fake news.
It's unbelievable.
Unfortunately, Fox has become fake news, too.
I don't know what happens to these people.
Right.
Do you agree, Trump even turning on Fox News
there, which I'm going to talk about more
tomorrow, saying Fox is fake news, but that
that's optics.
I care about numbers.
Trump said we're better than almost any country
on Corona virus.
Just as a reminder, we have the eighth most
cases per capita and the tenth most deaths
per capita out of more than two hundred countries
and territories.
Those are the numbers.
Then Trump went back to his terrible reading
of a poorly written speech and with one hundred
and seventy thousand dead Americans from Corona
virus.
Trump says of Joe Biden, Joe was bad on swine
flu.
Take a listen.
Look at all.
The fake news is not a credible threat.
There are a lot of that's a lot of fake news
back there, Scott.
At the end of Joe Biden's eight years as vice
president, nearly two million Americans of
prime working age have dropped out of the
workforce.
Our factories were stolen.
Our country was doing lousy.
He lost nearly 200000 manufacturing jobs.
He was, by the way, a disaster on swine flu.
He got a horrible rating in Gallup.
Look at the Gallup poll.
So they call it H1N1, right?
You remember H1.
Swine flu, H1N1, he calls it, by the way,
just to be thorough.
Out of curiosity, I went and looked at the
Obama Biden approval on swine flu in 2009.
About two thirds of the country approved of
the job they did across all regions of the
country, across all levels of concern about
swine flu.
So even their trump is wrong on the facts.
And, of course, is talking about something
completely unrelated to what is pressing now,
which is one hundred and seventy five thousand
really dead from Corona virus with 55000 additional
likely based on looking at excess death data
and.
Then, strangely, Donald Trump says Chicago
is worse than Syria.
That that's the argument.
I mean, you probably find it odd, but he said
Chicago is worse than Syria and Iraq.
The context was, of course, a bragging about
how he militarized our streets.
The drawbridges to prevent hordes of rioters
from ransacking the city.
Can you believe it?
Can you believe?
Seventeen officers were injured in Chicago.
They had a week.
A little while ago during a weekend spree
where 78 people were shot and 18 died.
That's worse than Afghanistan, which we're
getting out of.
That's worse than Iraq, which we're almost
out of.
That's worse than Syria, which we're out of,
except we get the oil.
But that's OK.
We'll have to talk about.
Chicago is worse than Syria and Iraq.
This is all really bad.
But the seeking the third term thing is being
weaponized and built up by his most deranged
followers.
And this is a presidency that is a testament
to ignorance.
The fact that he received 63 million votes
in 2016 when running on things like fixing
trade and dealing with China, which he obviously
has no clue of.
It was a completely obviously unsuited candidate
to the job.
But 63 million voted for him.
And it's a testament to ignorance.
The fact that he failed at everything during
his presidency most acutely corona virus and
is back up to polling 42 percent in the latest
Gallup presidential tracking poll is a testament
to ignorance.
And then the fact that he floats something
as authoritarian as a third term while sending
militarized troops to cities and kneecapping
the post office to try to prevent vote by
mail.
That is a testament to ignorance and to people's
own sort of tacit approval or indifference
to the authoritarianism they claim to opposed.
So we're in real trouble and we're in trouble
as far as the absentee ballots as well.
That's what I want to talk about next.